increase in testosterone and human
growth hormones decrease in
psychological stress which is just
anxiety
and physiological stress which is like
the physical cortisol stress hormone
you have a decrease in blood glucose
blood lipids
and increase in insulin sensitivity
dramatic decrease in body weight body
fat percentage and
improved body composition increased
response to injury to skin
so this could be chemical it could be
allergens irritant
heightened resistance to cancer diabetes
and heart disease
increased lifespan and counteracting
aging
if allah says something's good for you
you do it because allah knows best
and allah created you so you don't even
question it so if allah says fast
you gotta fast
[Music]
the way that your life is set right now
is basically
accommodating pornography
so you need to change your life in
little specific ways because it is
little changes that's gonna
result in the big changes so if you have
no purpose if you have no structure
can you guys believe that ramadan
is literally right around the corner a
few months away
get out of here bro like it's coming up
like
okay firstly people need to start making
up for their fasts and what they miss
because it's coming up
uh sisters brothers if you miss any days
fasting you have to make it up before
the next ramadan comes before it's too
late
but ramadan is coming up and it feels
like the last one just passed it felt
like the last two are aids in
in ramadan like it just happened and
maybe it's a quarantine that's throwing
me off
um but last ramadan was in quarantine
wasn't it
but i even had that was my best ramadan
so far really really do you want to talk
about that
i feel like just simply put bro being at
home being quarantined being in lockdown
it gives you a lot of time to reflect
and everyone's at home
everyone's going crazy because of kovitz
so either you guys all go crazy together
or
you work past it really connect with
allah detach from this dunya
yeah et cetera et cetera yeah subhan
allah and that's the thing because
fasting
forces you to do that fasting makes you
closer to allah because in essence
you're detaching yourself from the world
and naturally detaching yourself from
the world while bringing you closer to
the afterlife bring you closer to allah
and this is one of the beautiful parts
and aspects of fasting
for the full month of ramadan because
not only are the gates of heaven close
or the gates of heaven opened in the
gates of hell closed but
intrinsically internally when a person
abstains from food this has
different physical and spiritual
benefits for example
um i mentioned in a few podcasts of
casco that uh the prosthetic
he had a hadith which means that he
starts by saying allah the most high has
said
so this is allah saying that the most
beloved acts of worship to me
are the ones which i made obligatory
right
including fasting and salaam stuff and
then allah says and then the servant
continues to get closer and closer to me
with voluntary acts of good
until allah begins to love them and the
rest of the hadith goes on it's very
beautiful masha'allah if you guys want
to look it up
so the most beloved act of worship is
fasting the month of ramadan one of the
most beloved acts of worship fasting
ramadan and allah says there's
there's basically there's a hadith that
says there one thing that a servant does
for allah alone that's like that's for
allah and that's it
is fasting it's fasting and
it's amazing because even fasting has so
many benefits to it you would think that
if it's for allah and like that's it
and allah is going to reward you for it
immensely then like okay maybe there
isn't much that we get out of it
but no there is so much we get out of it
which maybe is why allah rewards us the
most because there's so much
hair and there's so much good in it
masha'allah for example
intrinsically when you remove food
right you create this sense of longing
right i need this food and you begin to
think about
the days when you had food and you were
ungrateful for it and the days where you
maybe forgot to say bismillah
and you forgot to end with alhamdulillah
and you forgot you even forgot allah
during the meal
you're working you're busy you're eating
eating the munchies
and then that's it right but during
ramadan you can't eat and it just
it makes you sympathetic towards the
poor people and it makes you grateful
towards allah and
it creates this feeling of this longing
for allah
and that's when you know reading the
quran comes in and and praying the salah
on time comes in
and then aid at the end when you
celebrate it's allah it's amazing it
just creates this taqwa this
consciousness of allah
and that is the state that every muslim
should strive towards
getting to just being conscious of allah
constantly which is why it's also sunnah
to fast mondays and thursdays
the the three white days of every month
and so on and so forth
hold up i got a white girl question to
ask what's up
not even water not even water
not even water no but the thing is
for anyone who doesn't know we wake up
in the morning before
uh sunrise and we eat our breakfast then
and then we fast until sunset and then
we have our dinner then and then we're
good until the next
a little bit before the next sunrise
yeah before before all you hippies come
in we don't
fast for the whole month straight yeah
you have eating windows and fasting
windows just like people that fast for
fat loss yeah and
the spiritual connection the spiritual
uplifting you get from ramadan is
something that i can't
i can't personally can't do justice with
with like with just words
it's something somebody has to
experience right and there are videos
out there people who
there's this one lady who made a video
fasting certain amount of days uh to get
closer to god
and i was like 700 000 views or
something like that there are people out
there that have this longing right
and they see fasting as a means towards
god something that that moses did
something that jesus did peace be upon
them
and it's something that's been kind of
reiterated in the scripture throughout
history
fasting is just one of those it's just
one of those things you know it's one of
those
acts of worship that not only is it
amazing in the sense that you know god
would love it if you have
you know the right intentions but it's
amazing in the sense that it brings you
closer to allah
right it creates that that beautiful
connection with allah
it's kind of reminding yourself how
dependent you are on allah and
everything
he provides and how ungrateful you
you've been this whole time
because i imagine you know allah is is
giving you all this stuff
for years for decades for lifetimes
and you're not like you don't even think
about it right you fast one day
one day and you can't handle it and
you're like man all those all those days
all those years those decades i was i
was ungrateful subhanallah
it's mind-boggling man 100
and i always look at it like there's
like three schools of thought right so
the first one's when
you you fully submit to allah you
believe in god
in allah you believe in one god you have
a man and this is where you
you kind of don't question things
anymore if allah says something's good
for you you do it because allah knows
best
and allah created you so you don't even
question it so if allah says fast
you've got to fast and this is a very
good school of thought because
once you form that you're mad provided
you're able to do it insha'allah
everything you do is going to be right
provided you take a lot of advice
and you're kind of protected from
shaytan and all that
now there's a second school of thought
which is like okay
i don't fully believe in islam i don't
fully
like i don't feel that yet but
if i had to pick one religion i'm going
to pick a song
like if there had to be one islam makes
the most sense logically speaking
and if you had this school of thought
insha allah what we're going to do today
is give you
level 2 type advice which is on talking
about scientific literature
clinical studies to kind of reaffirm why
physiologically and psychologically
speaking
fasting and specifically dry fasting
which we do in ramadan is extremely
beneficial to
our soul our body our mental health our
cognition everything the whole nine but
again the best school of the best mode
of action is to is to do level one which
is allah told you to do it
so just believe allah but if you're not
there yet again that's what we're trying
to do
we're not trying to replace dean with
science but we're using science to re
reaffirm and reinforce
the demon all right and then with that
being said it goes without saying
the third school of thought is just
people that aren't even there yet with
islam
let alone just believing in like full
feeling
iman so with these people again just
just keep doing you
uh i'm gonna give you advice that uh you
know on how always preachers
be in a very receptive state to be led
by
and if you're being present you should
be led to god inshallah
inshallah beautiful reminder
y'all got anything to say before uh
before we're going on
you excited for the first ramadan of
your life
yeah dude um i was actually thinking
and i had all these like random thoughts
of like oh
you know what maybe maybe i'll do
ramadan next year
because i'm so new and all this stuff
but it's like bro if
if i put it off i'm just gonna keep
putting it off like
but even even habib professional
professional mma athlete at the top of
the
the field still did ramadan
and he put off all fights he i think
he's still trained but he obviously
trained uh accordingly
yeah but um like he he stepped down to
do ramadan and i like
that stood out to me while i was like
alright yeah i gotta
i gotta put my my desires and my ego
aside here
yeah masha'allah
i feel like it's this fear of other
things that gets in the way of people
and just a side note before we dive into
you know fasting but
people got to realize when you put your
trust into allah
all you trust i'm talking about put all
your eggs in this basket everything else
falls into place
yeah because there's people here like oh
i don't i don't have time to pray i got
an exam coming up
so i'm only gonna study or i'm i'll do
mma bro so i gotta fight
you know i don't have time to pray i
don't have time to fast uh if i do that
it's gonna pull me away from
my purpose which is fasting and all that
but they fail to realize that if you
trust in
allah and allah has your back oh this
dunya is going to be at your feet
allah created everything here so so what
do you why are you putting off a lot
for dunya things yeah yeah
has anybody ever lost from trusting in
allah and doing what what he says has
anybody ever lost anything
no no lost by not listening to allah and
his commandments
hell yeah i have myself so i mean i
have you have everyone has bro
um it please bro
major yeah yeah big l
anyway before we go in guys quick
disclaimer this is not to
be interpreted or to replace any medical
advice
see a physician see a healthcare
provider if you're considering doing any
type of fasting including ramadan
if you feel like you're physically unfit
with that being said let's go straight
in
um i got a quick question for angel
though because you used to be a personal
trainer
i'm a personal trainer so i know some of
the language that i'm about to speak is
not going to be foreign to you
it might be a little bit to rami uh
unless he's been getting in that
intermittent fasting boy then it's not
going to be foreign to you
but bro what is intermittent fasting
it's basically you have a an eating
window
which means you have a certain amount of
time that you eat
and then the rest of the time you are
not eating you can drink water
or you cannot drink water if you're
trying to do the dry fasting but
you know if in normal terms what people
usually do for
intermittent fasting is they'll do a
16-8 protocol
where they'll fast for 16 hours
obviously they're sleeping anywhere from
six to eight of those hours
and then they have eight hours where
they eat where it's like they would eat
their first meal at 12
and then 6 p.m would be the cut off
actually no i take that back
um 8 p.m will be the cut off here that
would be eight hours
or if you do 10 o'clock then it'll be
six o'clock
it's really as simple as it's as simple
as that to be honest
1000 bro and i know these people got to
realize we're not
shaving off our calories if you eat 2
000 calories per day
all you do during intermittent fasting
is squish in those 2000
in your eating window of eight hours it
doesn't mean you're eating less per se
but there's a lot of benefits we're
going to talk about like i think it
boosts your human growth hormone by like
400 percent
testosterone by 200 so you're eating the
same
it just there's a limited window now all
right
so the first thing i want to get out
there i wanna i wanna kinda
you know angela talked about a bit let
me let me kind of clarify
there are two types of fasting there's
wet fasting and dry fasting right
he talked about dry fasting where he
said you could do it if you don't wanna
drink
drink water and it is harder i'm not
gonna lie
you might feel a little dehydrated the
first couple days so be on the lookout
for that
maybe you know use some salt in your
water put some pink salt in that
uh it'll help you stay hydrated but
essentially dry fasting is ramadan
ramadan-style fasting
dry fasting is just instead of what he
said the 16-8
which is 16 hours a day fasting you
could still drink water in that time
and the eight hours of eating and
drinking water you basically go
the whole 16 hours plus so it's up to
some people have done it for four or
five days um where you literally just
don't
drink water at all and what you what
what happens to your body when you stop
drinking water and you do dry fasting
is you enter the state called autophagy
ramy have you heard about that or not
all right so we got we got cells in our
body millions billions trillions we got
cells in our body
and what these cells do is they're
constantly replicating right
they're constantly dividing and that's
how we stay alive we got some cells that
have been part of us for
months if not years and we got some
cells that are regenerated every day
right what i'm trying to say with this
is we have a
finite number of cells though yeah
they're always dividing but we don't we
don't get
more and a lot of that could be dead
weight all right a lot of it could be
just
old cells that are toxic not really
functioning as well
what autophagy does the state i talked
about which you enter when you do dry
fasting
is you enter a state where you literally
kill off all the weakest cells in your
body
and you literally recreate new cells and
you replenish them
so it's almost like and guys this is
phenomenal because 1400 years ago nobody
knew about this
but what dry fasting is is all the cells
we have in our body that are not
functioning the best so it could be weak
nerve cells if you got weak nerve cells
it's just gonna affect your cognition
weak muscle cells
affect your your physique maybe have
more fat composition
you got weak digestive cells you're
probably not gonna you know digest the
best type of foods
as efficient so if you essentially kill
off all the weakest cells it's like
survival of the fittest
right and then only the strong cells
survive
and if only the strong cells survive
they're going to now divide
and replicate to be just like them and
create copies that are only superior
so it's essentially taking the only good
cells you have in your body
and making that 100 of your cells and
killing off the worst ones
all right so it's basically like an
immune system nervous system
muscular system reset in a way all right
so
there's been a lot of studies guys i
will link them all in the description
box down below
but the first thing i want to talk about
and we'll go step by step so
i'll say one or two of these points and
then i want to hear out your thoughts
what you guys have to say about that all
right
so the first thing a lot is decrease in
psychological stress so that would be
anxiety and
physiological stress which would be
court of law have you guys had any
experience with that what do you guys
think
with stress yes i have what
with the effects of it
bro repeat
i'm gonna tell you guys findings from
the studies
okay from dry fasting and ramadan and i
basically want you guys to tell me if
you could relate to any of these
if you've had any experiences if you
haven't not just with the symptoms that
i say
so the first one is decrease in
psychological stress which is just
anxiety
and physiological stress which is like
the physical cortisol stress hormone
will see a 100 especially recently okay
what about you
could you use it in a sentence uh
yeah i'm messing with you bro i'm
messing with you i'm not gay
but um yes of course
have you had any any experience with
that during dry fasting
uh you talking about the anxiety and all
that and the stress increased anxiety
decreased stress
yeah i've never like i've never done dry
fasting where it's like oh okay i'm
doing dry fasting while i'm like setting
out to do it but
i've done it unknowingly and
it's crazy 100
man i've done dry fasting
water fasting water fasting is basically
when you don't eat for three to five
days and you just drink water
and i still do this thing called the
intermittent fasting which is the 16 8
that he talked about i do that every day
all right next thing i want to say is
dry fasting kills all of our weak cells
which we already talked about
you have a decrease in blood glucose
blood lipids
and increase in insulin sensitivity
now a lot of big terms are on her what
could you say simply about insulin
sensitivity
oh boy hold up now
all right so insulin we all have insulin
we eat food we release insulin what
insulin's purpose
is it removes excessive amounts of
sugar that are in your bloodstream no
matter what you eat
even if it's fat or protein it is still
releasing a certain amount of sugar
still converting
to a certain amount of sugar so a
certain amount of uh
glucose that's what it's actually
released into glucose
a certain amount of glucose is going to
be released into your bloodstream
and the insulin literally it's released
i want to say bro correct me if i'm
wrong by your pancreas
and the pancreas releases the insulin to
be able to
remove any extra amount of glucose any
extra amount of sugar that you have
in your bloodstream because if you have
too much
a lot of bad things can start happening
that's the problem with um
diabetics is that they have way too much
sugar in their bloodstreams
almost to the point where they got to
inject exogenous forms of insulin
because the body can't produce it either
because of a resistance or they can't
produce enough
from a defect but insulin guys simply
put just like he said he said it best
it basically soaks up all the carbs and
all the sugar from your body and
delivers it into your liver for
glycogen storage or to your muscle cells
now
like he also said the reason we don't
want sugar just floating all about
freely
in your blood vessels is because sugar
is inflammatory
and lingering in there too long will
lead to you essentially attacking your
own blood vessels
which is not good it's very true all
right so
one more thing that we already talked
about before i said that is decrease in
blood glucose and blood lipids so again
all good things next thing is increase
in testosterone and human growth hormone
we already talked about that
increase in physical and emotional
well-being we talked about that
increased response to injury to skin so
this could be chemical
it could be allergens irritants and
rapid wound healing
what are your thoughts on that
um okay i will say that the first time
that i
went into a fast which was a water fast
actually i take that back because i did
do fasting before that
um but the first legitimate legitimate
fast why was i
i'm gonna do a water fast i remember i
had a lower back injury
herniated disc and it's always kind of
acting up every now and then but when i
did that water fast man like
it healed pretty quick
phenomenal bro
romney anything you gotta say i mean
i've never really been
i don't know i've never really like
taken the time to observe these things
like oh
after i fasted you know this this not
happened right because it's been a part
of my life like my entire life so it's
never really been
you know something i would observe i got
a question then
yeah what about your broken heart my
broken heart
um honestly
fasting i think anything that connects
you to allah
removes you or anything that yeah
connected to allah or moves you from the
dunya
a broken heart is a part of this dunya
so fast and getting close to allah would
remove
that from you uh inevitably that's the
one thing that you know
i use and that many people use when they
go through a hardship is just the
connection with allah
well i feel so bad for people who don't
have that because like what do they have
to latch on to
right 100 man talk about short-term
gratification and stuff but um
fasting yes for a broken heart
phenomenal phenomenal man you guys have
heard it here first rami al-khalil gave
you that five out of five rating
uh thank you for that brother but he is
right guys all
all these damn jokes aside fasting is a
remedy it prevents you from fascia which
is
which is just filth and just dirt and
just sins
in general insha allah and there was a
there was a hadith with the prophet
sallam said
to talking to the youngsters to the
youth any of you that can support a wife
get married
and if you can't support a wife fast for
fasting diminishes sexual power
and the term that they use in the hadith
in arabic they're not talking about
diminishes and decreases that or like
you know kind of
lowers your your you know drive not the
term they use
if you if you want to translate it to
english the actual translation is
castration
it's as if you've been castrated that's
how much you literally feel like
you're not going to feel that that
sexual drive anymore
yeah anyway carrying on uh subhanallah
so increased response to overall
infections and pathogens guys we already
talked about this before
uh you basically kill off your weaker
cells so let's talk about immune cells
only the strongest immune cells that you
have survive so basically your immune
system is going to be on 10.
um heightened resistance to cancer
diabetes and heart disease
increased lifespan and counteracting
aging any thoughts on that
interacting aging martial
as i feel like i feel like that's a big
one for a lot of people
a lot of people when they get old they
just they lose it you know what i mean
100 man 1400 years ago
there was also hadith where the prophet
saws said uh you know to there was this
guy
laying uh laying on his stomach
somewhere i don't know if you know about
that but the
the prophet saws went and you know he
was kind of like just nudging his face
and
trying to get him up and he woke up and
he said don't sleep like that allah
hates that position
and the guy was just kind of like
confusing and a lot of people might be
confused why
and at the end of the day like 1400
years ago nobody understood it but they
they submit to that they listen to that
because they knew that allah didn't like
it
now in class we're talking about spinal
mechanics and spinal surgery
and it's crazy how you literally learned
that the position of sleeping that puts
you
in the most compromised state of your
spinal health i'm talking about
disc bulges i'm talking about this slips
and all that it's gonna be sleeping on
your stomach
and what's crazy is i had this issue
personally where i would sleep on my
stomach all the time
and i woke up with neck pain and back
pain and it's just crazy man but
unless i said the best all right next
one i want to talk about
is overall decrease in inflammation
arthritis and mobility issues
any experience with that
yes i've never had issues with that
personally to be honest
i had tendonitis in my right forearm
and i remember um i had done
another water fast and literally like it
didn't heal 100
but i'd say it healed close to about
like seventy to eighty percent
in a few days so supanolites
it's incredible what fasting does to the
body
okay 100 men
uh could be attributed to the lack of
blood sugar in your body
because now we know you know
inflammation is caused by sugar and
you're kind of lowering your blood
glucose
through dry fasting but again that's
just my
causality it might be might not be next
thing is dramatic decrease in body
weight body fat percentage and in
improved body composition any experience
with that
i don't know i i don't know if i could
actually give
like a personal experience i know when i
did
any form of fasting like i would flush
out all the water and
i would just look ridiculously lean and
in terms of like
muscle mass proportion to fat it would
be a
greater muscle mass and less fat as to
what i could see
but i've never done like a dexa scan or
anything like that where it said like
okay well here's the difference you know
i agree man and like logically speaking
rationally speaking it makes sense
because your human growth hormone and
testosterone is through the roof
so body recomposition body
fat just flushing out same with water it
makes sense
mom you got any experience with that
i've been skinny my whole life man
you've been skinny your whole life
you're ready your first
um next one is gonna be no
adverse effect for cardiovascular and
respiratory system so this was a
meta-analysis where they talked about
people being like okay
i don't want to fast because what if it
harms me what if it's dangerous
because again these are people that are
post-modern you know
today's men and women and they're out
here you know
we live in a world where ubereats is
available in five minutes you got a
pizza at your door
so they don't realize that back then or
in nature in the wild they don't have
that bro they don't have food
delivery just ready at their fingertips
what they got to do is they got to go
through periods of time
prolonged periods of time where they got
to be in hunting mode
and because they don't have food right
so in this period of time they got to go
out here
scout and get that food when they do
finally get that food
after that three four day mark then they
got food for like a couple days
all right this is when they're kind of
you know chilling they're good
they eat that meal they relax they rest
they recover and then they go back to
that
so it kind of makes sense how like in
nature those hardwired things are still
in our body
the way that allah designed to
subhanallah because when we go into that
fasting state
it's almost like we're in that hunting
state because i know personally speaking
cognition focus alertness productivity
all those things go up in your fasting
window
at least in the beginning compared to
when you're when you're eating all day
you guys got any experience with that yo
and and technically speaking
all right if someone were to eat
in abundance and you know in
um in personal training or just in
bodybuilding
or fitness in general is is referred to
as caloric intake
so like someone could be eating 2 500
calories a day
another person could be eating 3 000
calories a day that would be
your uh we'll call it maintenance level
you would eat that much to maintain
what you have like your body weight
composition all that good stuff
all right but like if you ate a surplus
like let's say 500 or a thousand
calories over that maintenance
you're probably gonna put on some fat
maybe a little bit of muscle if you're
training
but probably more fat than muscle all
right now
if if you were to include several days
in the week or even
one day in the week where you're just
fasting completely you don't even eat
that day
that would be the same as you eating
maintenance
every single day but now the days where
you do it you are
able to eat and i'm not going to say
anything you want because
it doesn't work like that it doesn't
work like that but you can eat in excess
and not have to worry about like gaining
weight because like technically
at the end of the week the amount of
calories you're getting in is
still equal to the amount you'd be
getting in if you were eating
at maintenance every single day so it
gets pretty interesting the more you get
into it
100 100 that was a good point
um next thing and guys based on this all
we're trying to say is
this is to like reaffirm the person that
is growing up in this
kind of soft world where they got food
every now and then they got snacks they
got
eight different meals all day uh
delivery
on deck post mates you name it so
back then we didn't have that we were
hunters we didn't have food at our
disposal
even if we're not talking about like you
know homo sapiens and like before that
even if we're not talking about that
even if we're talking about just
early primitive modern humans
right not the 2020 i'm talking about
centuries ago
thousands of years ago right we still
didn't have food at our fingertips we
had to still hunt we had to ration
we had to forage so because of that it
makes sense that
we're not naturally supposed to be in a
state where we're eating 24 7.
all right all right next thing i want to
say is because of that
fasting has been proven to have no
adverse effect on cardiovascular and
respiratory systems
contrary to people that might be
worrying about that no adverse effect on
hematologic profiles
and endocrine and neuropsychiatric
functions so you're not going to have
anything wrong with these things for
people that are wondering
and i remember like when i was in high
school i was like i had this uh
i had this course organic chemistry in
uh in grade 12
camp it was like a unit in that and it
was like people were struggling with
that man like everyone was
scared it was the first time we did orgo
in our life little did i know i do like
years of that after that in uni but
again besides the point crazy and people
were
losing their minds now that was the the
first time
y'all did oral orgo or go or go okay
go ahead it was it was kind of oral bro
cuz some people just got there
got their bottoms handed to them bro in
that final but uh
anyway with that being said when we did
this course it was ramadan
and here i'm thinking i've always fasted
in the summer
but you know how the days it gets pushed
back 20 days
or it comes it comes uh push back 20
days every year
something like that right so if it's may
20th this year
i think next year it'll start with 20
days ish before
and just that's just how it goes on
because the islamic calendar is not the
lunar calendar and when
ramadan hit just give me a sec
yo can you see me now i got a random
call bro from
slovakia i don't even know where that is
bro don't don't
don't play bro you know your girl just
called you nah
you playing you bugging out bro and i
don't even know where slovakia is
whoever the whoever just called they
called i didn't even click the client
they just they just hung up so
you're lost or whatever um anyway as
we're saying
uh what was i talking about remind me
i don't remember honestly we're talking
we're talking about logo
and it's ramadan now used to be in the
summer but now it's kind of towards the
last month of the year
and we're here like damn bro like i got
i got to study
you know these are these are some hard
exams and
you could also fast and kind of put your
faith in a lot
well i realized i got this far only with
them so what i'm gonna do is i'm just
gonna fast
yeah i gotta study during the fast i
don't know how it's gonna be
but bro and i'm not saying this to like
boost
myself or to my own horn but i was
getting like
95s in high school in my final year
and in every single organic chem midterm
i got 100 like i got perfect in all of
them i didn't even miss
one mark on all of them and i remember
fasting like
thirsty like literally like struggling
for allah's cause
and literally like during lunch hour
when everyone would eat
i would go home so i'd run all the way
home just like study
right just to get my extra like you know
repetition memorization you know get
everything done come back to school
and then just perform and subhanallah
bro this was all
100 so also brings me to my next point
where um you have higher than
non-fasting psychomotor function visual
attention
visual learning memory and sleep quality
all right so these were the findings for
cognition
so it's not really a bad thing guys to
uh do ramadan
now last thing i want to say cogni uh
contrary to
normal people's belief ramadan fasting
has
only been shown to mildly influence the
immune system
and those who are already altered so
it's not going to get too much worse
but most people it gets better ramadan
fasting during the second trimester
of pregnancy was also shown to be safe
and did not
result in negative fetal outcomes
contrary to anyone that might be
wondering should i fast
um but again obviously talk to your
gynecologist and all that don't just
take this advice
um and there's no maternal oxidative
status
alterations as well just to get that out
there in cardiac benefits
ramadan fasting only had beneficial
effects
including lipid profile improvement and
alleviation of oxidative stress
oxidative stress we talked about it also
leads to cancer so less of that is
obviously good and asthmatic patients
and those with immunodeficiencies
in their immune system and their
respiratory system are good things
and as psychiatric patients are good
things including schizophrenia so
i don't know why anyone would not fast
subhan allah
that is like overwhelmingly amazing like
overwhelmingly amazing
yeah man link in description for anyone
that wants to read more on this
that's amazing i feel like anyone who
doesn't fast after this
must severely like dislike themselves
how do you hear of all these amazing
spiritual and and and
even if you don't believe in like a
spear or spiritual side um
all these uh mental and physical
benefits
and not want to fast afterwards like
it's it's final law
it's crazy excuses
you guys don't have to like overwhelm
yourself like guys there's
yeah it might you know come up end of
january or february this podcast episode
but
it'll be what three months two to three
months until ramadan
so that gives you guys enough time if
you haven't fasted before you don't want
to fast you think there's some health
risks
you don't want to do dry fasting do
water fasting or like
wet fasting all that is is you basically
eat
but you don't eat any time you have that
limited eating window like
angel talked about maybe from 12 p.m to
8 p.m
every single day that's you're allowed
to eat that's it
out of those hours you're sleeping
fasting
nothing else all right you could drink
water but don't eat
food all right once you get good with
that doing it every now and then you can
even start it once a week then you can
do the fast of dawud
al-assalam which the salon would fast
every other day
all right and you guys have to like
clarify the next thing that i'm about to
say i don't know if it's like 100
percent but
it's known that the prophet sallam
apparently so that's what i'm saying you
guys got to
check this out said that do not fast on
friday
unless you are fasting the day before
and the day after
that's why you know he would fast
thursday only fast friday if you're
fasting on thursday
and saturday that's basically what that
means so
guys fast more slowly once you get used
to that start fasting every day
if you could do intermittent fasting
then start dry fasting
go at least the first day couple hours
after you after you wake up without
water
then the next day go to let's say 1 1
p.m then
2 p.m then 3 p.m over time you'll
realize
you're making it to like 4 or 5 6 p.m
without drinking water and you're fine
all right don't take what i'm saying now
and just then go to sleep after
that limited time that you do have to
drink water get your daily supply in
but what you'll realize is it's almost
magritan which is when we break up fast
and you haven't drink to drink drink any
water and it's fine
and you're alive and you're healthy so
once you get that
baby step in because self-improvement
happens in uh happens in steps
i think one of the goats said that
allah one thing i want to mention is the
prophet saws he actually said
don't do the fasting of dawood alaihi
because he was a prophet of allah that's
why that's why he did that but we're
instructed not to not to do that
but uh prosthetic like we mentioned he
fasted mondays and thursdays
and the three white days of every month
which i believe is like the 14 15 16
or something like that every month but
like look it up look it up
yo quick question what time do you guys
think we started recording
what time is it right now it's 501 right
now
yeah what time do you guys think we
started recording
uh i'm gonna send the link
i sent it at 422 so around 4 30.
around 4 30. damn bro 30 minutes and
we already got this one's done not even
30 bro it feels like two hours man
i'm getting like lecture vibes from this
one what else
there's like a look at what else you
guys have to talk about if there's
anything you want to share
there was one point that i forgot to
mention about the spiritual aspect
it does tie in with the the physical
aspect of it
or a naturalistic uh aspect of it but
uh about the hadith he referred to with
about the process i said where he said
that um
fasting kind of diminishes like desires
or sexual drive
um that's another spiritual aspect right
and naturalistically if you could look
if you could look at it in this sense
um we have uh you guys know like the
pyramid of things that humans
you know give means yes yes thank you
um the first one or one of the ones at
the top
would be uh food nutrition survival all
that stuff right
and under that would be the sexual drive
procreation recreation all that stuff
right and
if you're not getting what's at the top
your body's going to stay stuck on there
you're going to be focused on eating
getting food and all that
just not on the bottom because it's like
the base foundation
okay yeah maybe because you basically
work from bottom up
in the hierarchy of meat so you start at
the bottom with the basic physiological
ones that you talk about okay that makes
it so what's at the top then
self-actualization that's like that's
like the highest things like you don't
do those unless you're doing what you
said basically like you're making sure
the lower level needs are met
yeah okay so the lower level needs are
like the basic you know bread and butter
okay jessica here thank you thank you so
yes at the bottom then
would be um things like food uh survival
all that stuff
and then above that would be uh the
sexual drive and you know
uh getting your um
kind of procreation out there right
getting your rocks off yeah
i'm trying to think about it i think the
term is called i think the term is
called love and belongingness
but basically same thing yeah yeah so
better than saying better than saying
getting your rocks off bro yeah yeah
yeah come on
my bad i'll be more modest insha'allah
but um
so if you're stuck at the bottom right
you're not gonna be able to work your
way up if you're stuck on not having
food or drinking you need that your
body's gonna focus on that
before it's like okay let's go um i was
going to use the term again i'm not
going to use it
yeah let's go procreate
i want you to say copulate
what copulate copy what does that mean
google it up bro i want you to i want
you to google the definition and read it
out to us
all right this is for educational
purposes
this is for educational purposes y'all
do not hold me accountable
this is all on her bro this is this word
is from
unhealth all right you guys ready i
don't think i've ever said it
all right it's a verb right
this is the oxford uh definition and it
means
to have sexual intercourse
and yeah but doesn't it doesn't it sound
so like there's more there's more
only the dominant male copulates with
only the doms man that's why i talked
about her man like
don't say something about it maybe prime
will scream bro
yo is your mom home she's home bro
goddamn guys you won't be able to see it
then
maybe on a patreon exclusive
fifty dollars a month to hear this guy
scream
that's the next two that's not all they
get they get the only fans from fire
and they get the sound cloud from little
queasy
guys don't miss out man one life
next thing i want to talk about is the
actual
thing of how we fast and how we can
optimize
the two meals that we have now the two
meals that we have aren't limited to the
only two that we have during
but they're primarily the two meals that
we as in
the islamic tradition we practice all
right so the first one is if thought
so if god is the meal that we break our
fast with all right it happens as soon
as maghrib is done
matter of fact allah says put food in
your mouth before you come pray for if
you come and pray first
your mind's gonna be on food and you're
not gonna be present so
this is when you to you know take that
sip what i usually do for f thought
is i usually have like dates because the
prophet saws broke as fast with dates
and i drink some water or some juice
anything just to rehydrate myself
not too heavy and then i go praise a lot
because i still want to pray on time
after that i come and then i i eat
properly
you know what i mean like i go in with
their thought if thought
usually i eat something super high
glycemic
which is just really carby it'll get
absorbed by your body fast and i have
some protein with that
i try to limit my fat and then you know
get the water in through the night
now the second meal i want to talk about
in the islamic tradition is
seri so suhoor is the meal we eat before
we start the fast so this is right
before federer
once it's fragile you cannot eat or
drink anymore until maghrib
so for what i usually typically eat is
something high fat and high protein
something like steak growing up you
might have had uh
you know some nice rice and some biryani
and some
nice stuff like that on the on the table
bro but that's gonna make you feel
really hungry
you're gonna wake up with acid reflux
you're gonna feel that that sting that
burning sensation
you're not going to make it through the
day but if you're having something slow
digesting like steak which takes
hours to digest or you're going to be
fine so that's what i typically do for
saloon
these are the two main meals you can
obviously eat in between that
in terms of the sleep schedule too i've
had a pretty interesting experience
whenever it's ramadan
i basically stay up till fajr and i wake
up around the hard time
right which is again it kind of gets in
the way but if i have work or school or
something like that then i kind of have
to like modify with it
but again allah comes first everything
else follows naturally
yeah let me just chime in and say that
uh
the heartburn the acid reflux that
varies from person to person
but what you are saying about if you're
eating like a whole bunch of carbs
for your meal then when you are fasting
you're gonna feel like trash because
your body is going to in short
like in the most simplistic terms your
body's gonna use up all the carbs real
quick
and then you're gonna be left uh
in a state where your body's trying to
switch
from using glucose as energy to using
ketones as energy using your fat as
energy
and like it's your body is very
efficient your body will do it
but it's like if you're not used to it
then you actually have to go through
that process and
not only psychologically speaking but
physiologically speaking is very tough
on you
um so if someone wants to ease
in to this transition um he's into
fasting
they could definitely start a
keto-based way of eating before
the fasting and that way they'll notice
when they are in the fasting window
they're not going to feel that terrible
just something to keep in mind 100
percent of my own value
i personally recommend all my clients
and anyone doing ramadan for the first
time not to do ketosis
during ramadan because keto already
makes you naturally more dehydrated
because of the lack of water you're
going to flush out all the water anyway
so for you to go that into dry fasting
most people might be a little
symptomatic with that so that's why i
recommend the carb back loading approach
which is super carb up during the
iftar when you're already insulin
sensitive and you're fine with the carbs
but then kind of go into a little more
keto type of meal like anh said for
because one the two biggest precursors
of acid reflux
which is basically that feeling you have
when you feel like you have gas and
you're kind of really hungry and that
stinging sensation
one you have it when you eat and go to
sleep what are people doing they eat
sukhur they pray fajr go right back to
sleep
right second thing they're eating a
whole bunch of carbs and again
carbs are going to cause acid reflux
because like anaheim said you're eating
carbs so much to the point where your
body almost expects it
then you go into deprivation for a
couple hours and your body's gonna still
expect those carbs
so what is it still doing it's still
creating those digestive enzymes
and that's gonna decrease the ph of your
stomach increase the acidity
but you're not giving the food so we're
just gonna keep doing that and then
you're gonna get really hungry bro
yeah that's why i said like you would do
the keto
before the fasting because it takes your
body about like four to six weeks
to actually adapt so if someone were to
adapt and then do the fast
well then they wouldn't have the
dehydration issues but
if they would start keto right around
the same time they're about to fast
ooh they ain't for a hard time bro
um but most most people that i know that
are muslim
they've been fasting since they were
like damn near 12 maybe even earlier
so for us it would be almost second
nature for new reverts
yeah it is something that you guys want
to definitely be mindful of
there's one thing i wanted to add um
maybe i don't know if
i missed it did you say that you wake up
around the afternoon time or is this a
nap
no i sleep from fajr to tahar bro okay
okay yeah because the prophet said
uh what he would usually do um rather
regardless of whether it was ramadan or
not
he would uh he would wake up at fajr he
would stay up he would take a nap
at duhor and then he would he would wake
up for maybe
i don't know 10 minutes late or
something like that and he would stay up
the rest of the day
so that's that's well i'm pretty sure he
got most of his sleeping before fuji
yeah i'm not i'm not getting any sleep
you're not getting any
no that's what i'm saying i stay up till
fajr i sleep after fajr
and i wake up that's just what worked
for me
multi multi-man does the same thing but
again that being said it's not something
that's advisable for me myself
included when i'm doing something like
work or i have like you know
school or something like that this is
just like i'm talking about this coveted
season i did that because
it just worked for me that's fair that's
fair because it helped me to get my
before you go on it help me to also get
in my two to three liters of water
during my window because imagine i just
have iftar which is the meal of the mug
rib
yeah how much water could you drink one
to two glasses and then go to sleep
yeah how much water could you drink at
fudge or one or two glasses that's two
to four glasses
maximum whereas for me my whole eating
window like on how
terms it was from maghrib until fudger
so that whole 8 9 p.m till 4 5 a.m
all i was doing is just getting in water
and food okay i see it
and also training you trained at the
time too
yeah i trained all the time but mostly i
would train right before my grip
which is literally the time people are
just drained they fasted the whole day
they feel diminished and that's when i
did it bro because i
further improved my insulin sensitivity
which happens when you weight train
and then i just ate so i'm literally
like that's a bodybuilding meal right
there bro this man is trying to max out
1000 bro yeah i guess that makes sense
because back then they could only do the
work during the day
when the sun is out 100 percent didn't
do
there was no electricity and all that
yeah yeah so that makes sense that makes
sense
[Music]
all right i mean it was a blessing in
disguise because no electricity no
phones means when the sun is down you're
down
yeah and that's naturally aligned with
that circadian rhythm
yeah it's a panel all right man i say we
cut it off here
you all got anything else to say i need
to fix my sleeping schedule
we all got something to fix man yeah all
good in this video is from allah
and the messenger sallallahu salaam
allah bad is from us and shaytan
that being said romney you have
something to say um get those fasts and
ladies and gents ramadan is coming up
don't sleep on it
we just talked about how beneficial it
is so if
if the spiritual side isn't enough for
you there are
physiological benefits there are even
psychological benefits
the full like you like the full spectrum
there's no going wrong with this unless
you have pre-existing health issues
again
go see specialists about that but um
that's uh that's it for me if you guys
have anything to add before we close out
yeah let me just add this in here
and i'm not trying to be funny all right
because i bet you anyone watching my
house man about to say something
some goofy but uh if you guys actually
looking to dry fasting
there's this dude on youtube his name is
uh
i think cole robinson i might be messing
up his last name
but he's the inventor of this thing
called the snake diet
have you guys ever heard of that um
right so in this
in the snake diet he basically talks
about
dry fasting and like at first he was
only talking about fasting
but then this man got on to dry fasting
how he was like
he i think he did like seven seven days
of dry fasting like no water no food
seven days straight
so like a little bit more intense than
what would be done
in ramadan because obviously ramadan
you're eating but this man did like
seven i think
seven days maybe it might be less i'm
not recalling 100
and like he was over here like touting
the benefits
and he was just saying his experience
and
all of this good stuff so again like
romney said if
you're not doing for the spiritual side
like get into it for the physical
aspects but
yo spiritual is the most important
at some point or another you're going to
come to know that yeah that's facts
but physicality is important too like
like ramy always says like allah trusted
us with these bodies
so we can't be out here doing it at the
service because it's
there's narrations of the prophet saws
descriptions of how he looked he had an
aesthetic physique guys
most of our uncles and fathers and yeah
bro don't even get me started on that
most of
the people we got in our family or the
people we have like uncles and
grandfathers they got into dad bots
maybe they'd be getting these uh
unhealthy foods in
not drinking enough water not exercising
bro prophetic times
these were not weak people yeah mentally
or physically they looked
like doms and they were dumbs they
weren't out here just
kind of like you know soft and eating
and whatever and not really focusing on
their health
the prophet saws had an aesthetic
physique he had a good build
so let me ask you all some why do you
all think
that a lot of the uh religious people
the imams the shakes um
religious people in general why do you
think a lot of them are out of shape no
idea
i feel like it's it's a very vast
majority of them it's not like one or
two here and there it's like
it's almost all of them to be honest
that's my point bro it's
it's believe it or not it's social
conditioning it's not your moms in
general if you go to a church you'll see
pastors like that too
you'll see rabbis like that too i'm
talking about the average man and woman
today
yeah social conditioning and programming
cultivates this
false sense of acceptance and body
positivity
in this veil under the true motive of
unhealthy body weight obesity
dvd whatever you want to call it bro
society
is putting it out there that there is no
consequence to apathy
and looking like trash and that needs to
stop bro
because at some point health is going to
catch up with you
yes but aside aside from social
conditioning
do y'all feel like it might be some like
mental thing as well where it's like
the person might say ah well this is
dunya this is a test you know how i look
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day
or like they might just be comfortable
because ah well you know i'm married
and my wife is uh
is more she's she's part of the dean
she's very
religious so she cares more about that
she we put god first so it doesn't
matter how i look at the end of the day
i agree but at the end of the day a lot
talks about finding that happy medium
where you don't go too much on the one
side or one extreme of something
which is just like over fanatics of
islam
there's a difference between properly
being a muslim and being a fanatic and
extremist
so i'm talking about that and then the
other extreme doing nothing
so with regards to balance what you're
saying i do think there's a lot to do
with it because these people have
falsely accepted that
okay since there is an akhirah since
there is a hereafter this dunya doesn't
matter
but what they fail to realize allah
didn't just give you the akhidah allah
gave you this dunya first
and it's a test and you're failing these
tests now looking your best and the
prophet saw islam um
through his example we learned that as a
muslim we need to be balanced in
everything
our temperament needs to be calm yet
aggressive but knowing when to do so
we got a 100 percent balance the dunya
and akhila
obviously akira is the
it's the end to the means do you know
what i mean but we need to balance both
um in terms of like our desires we need
to limit our desires in a lot of things
like when it comes to eating when it
comes to
sinning when it comes to desires but
then we need to go
in on other desires like our desire to
procreate
and have as many kids as we can
permissibly um
things like that so i feel like balance
is key and most men
and women today lack that so when i go
to the masjid and i see imams
they they know a lot of you know
different verses there they memorize
everything they know exactly what
they're talking about in terms of the
sunnah and hadith in the quran
yeah in regards to how they look how
they want to be
you know respected what they know about
you know
post-modern times and like how they can
integrate that into
into the deen they kind of lack that and
that's why you see all those people
commenting down below like these are
topics that moms won't talk about
and it's not that no shade of these are
moms or anything like that
it's just that they're from different
times
and what you see today is most kids
are from our times too much too extreme
so there will be two postmodern there
will be two like
oh let's forget about islam you know
what i mean most people aren't like
us and the viewers here inshallah that
are trying to like integrate the two
still trying to be a good muslim salafi
man or woman
living in today's post-modern time
yeah um go ahead bro i honestly i think
even the way you described it is still
social conditioning especially the part
where it's like
oh you know my my wife you know she
loves me before i am and
that's social conditioning because why
are you getting in shape for her to
begin with right that's social
conditioning
so wait say that one more time you're
right yeah it's it's it's social
conditioning to say oh i want to look
good for my wife oh she loves me the way
i am therefore i'm fine
you don't you why do you need to look
good for her then this it's free allah
gave you a body
you take care of it for allah for the
sake of god you're right bro cause like
they'll
they'll put this thinly veiled excuse of
oh the quran says my wife owes me sex
like she has to do it yeah it says that
but bro are you a man that she wants to
do it with too
because it also says you can't force it
and how you gonna want her to be desired
and attracted to you
if you're not worth someone yeah
populating with
yeah and exactly and uh there's this one
sahaba the name slips my mind now but
there's one sahaba that used to always
comb his hair and make sure he's proper
before entering the home
because he wanted his wife you know
obviously to be attracted to him and
it's not that he was ugly or anything
but he just took the extra step and
cleanliness i know it's a separate topic
but it's similar cleanliness and islam
is it's like half of iman it's it's a
big part of
faith to be clean be to have that proper
hygiene
and taking care of yourself as well
allah gave you
he entrusted you with this body and
you're not taking care of it and the
reason your reason for not taking care
of the body allah gave you is because of
somebody else what
because your wife loves knowing that
because because the the key to jannah is
salah and the key to salah is
purification and cleanliness so
it all ties back to what romney's saying
guys i know you got something to say
yeah i mean again i don't think it's
just social conditioning
like i'm sorry but when i was getting
super spiritual
before islam like i i just stopped
caring about how i looked
and i let myself go big time
like i'm talking about like i went from
being the stacked individual
like bro mashallah diesel
if i look back at pictures of myself i'm
like wow like i can't believe i actually
look like that
because i went from that to looking like
a hobo
bro like fresh off the dunk like fresh
out of the street bro
but people were looking at me and be
like who is this guy and like i would
just
always say that it doesn't matter like
you shouldn't judge me
on my physical appearance cause like at
the end like this is just
a sack of meat this is just a body like
i
am the spirit i am the rook you know i
didn't know about the rule i just knew
about the spirit back then
so it's like again i don't think it's
just social conditioning i think
is also a mental thing where it's like
once you do
start learning more not even learning
more but just like
being woke to the truth once you start
being more woke to the truth
you kind of have this like mental
paradigm shift where it's like oh well
does it really matter what i look like
but then again like we said
yeah we should take care of ourselves
because this body is a gift this body
is uh almost like alone like you say
that all the time that
our bodies are lone to us and it's like
when you guys are talking about the
cleanness and you're saying that the
salat
is the uh the way to jannah well like
think about all the people who get to
the point where they can't really
they can't use their body that well they
got a broke hit or like their knee don't
work or something like that
it's like bro you don't see them
performing just a lot
the way they did when they were younger
you see them on a chair
doing like some variation of it so it's
like again
not saying that their prayers aren't
accepted because i'm not the one
to judge but it's like you could prevent
that if you take care of your health and
your body
yeah that is true and the prophet saw
always said bro
uh before you go on that you know when
you when you look at these people that
are just
out of shape to the point where they
can't they can't even perform salah
that's why the prophet saws never ate to
the point of being full
he always ate to the point where he
nursed and recharged and
rejuvenated his himself in terms of
energy but then he never over ate
he never indulged and that's amazing
that's profound because then you have
energy to go pray
you see what i mean and you're not going
to be out here you know feeling heavy
this whole density thing just stems from
that bro and i think you are right in
terms of the mental thing that you
brought up that aspect because it is
when you get
too into dhaka and too into things that
matter
you forget this dunya you forget oh damn
like i've seen people that are like
they're imams or shakes and they're
proper but it's like damn bro two three
days they haven't showered or like they
don't
yeah yeah these people also don't care
about instagram followers and
and looking good and all this because
they're focused on the goal but
you gotta also realize this balance
between yeah that prize is important
which is
allah and akhida but you still live in
the dunya
where most people sorry to say are not
at that level
and how you gonna relate to them and be
integrated into the society
if you want someone that is respected by
the means that they have yeah i'm not
saying be a cloud chaser and position
yourself
to be respected by these people and be
liked and put that over allah
but what i am saying is why not have
both there's a fine line between
sacrificing
the dunya or sacrificing the akhirah for
the dunya but you could definitely do
your best to have the akra
but also position yourself in a place
where people look up to you
because your physicality does have a lot
to do i know people say we don't judge
we don't shame over here bro whether you
like to admit it or not
we judge we subconsciously judge these
snap judgments happen every single day
every damn minute we see a new person
and the first thing that your body says
about you is damn bro this guy's
committed this guy's
he respects himself he has integrity he
has discipline
because you can't just get a body like
that just not having those and when i
look at someone that's fair out of shape
i don't
i don't look at them and i'm like damn
bro like i have you know i despise them
or anything nah i have pity i feel bad
because
at the end of the day i look at them and
i'm like that's a reflection of their
insecurities
unresolved problems they have in their
head deep dark trauma
that's that shows lack of self-esteem
lack of discipline
lack of just being a man or woman of
your word lack of self-control
like if you're a little overweight it's
fine but i'm talking about the people
that are so far gone
and you wonder like how they got there
but even that in and of itself
is judgment it's just a higher level of
consciousness
form of judgment because back then when
we were
ignorant when we were giants we would
look at an overweight person and be like
look at this pig
look at look at this muck yeah and if
y'all know about pokemon then y'all know
the
you y'all will know the reference there
but like yeah we used
to much how you spell mark let's see if
you're true pokemons
i'm uk that's my nose bro
bro you can't you can't do me on pokemon
your votes
my things but um real talk like
that's how we would judge you know and
like you ask a little kid
like that's how a kid judge a kid would
look at a fat person like oh look at
this fat person
don't literally like blatantly just say
like oh look at this
look at this fat person like why are you
fat or something like that
and they'll laugh about it but that's
like that's just
that's coming from a state of like uh
innocence like they don't know any
better but like
as you start growing um you become a
teenager you start learning more then
it's like you you get into this state
where you're super judgmental because
now your
your your mind has fully developed your
uh
not your mind but your brain has fully
developed to the point where now your
your mind is more dominant that's why we
perceive things differently
and that's why we uh actually start to
form a sense of ourselves even more and
that's why people start saying like oh i
have
anxiety i have depression on myself
because now their mind
is developed to the point where they can
have these issues versus when they were
a kid they didn't really have these
issues
but to get back on track here it's like
as you keep progressing as you keep
waking up more and more
and you get to the point where it's like
i want now you know more the truth
you still judge like there's not there's
not a person here who doesn't judge
and like there's brother there's people
who are like super spiritual and they
say oh
i don't judge anyone bro that's a damn
lie
yeah that's a damn lie uh i feel like
the topic of judgement is a really funny
one nowadays because every every time
like you you judge somebody negatively
you're judging them right but people
don't understand like okay like if me as
an individual i go and i see a fat
person i say damn they're fat that's
ugly
i've judged them and everyone will will
agree and concede to the fact that i
just judged that person
but if i see a built guy and i say wow
that's amazing i'm still
judging it's just not negatively you can
still judge
positively right you're still judging at
the end of the day so if you were to say
don't judge anyone
then you can't really compliment anybody
either because now you're judging them
their work who they are
and praising them as a result of your
intrinsic internal judgment on them
so the whole don't judge me thing is
kind of just don't ever comment on me
ever
right that's not very beneficial because
as humans we we like compliments so it's
basically just
uh if there's anything negative about
myself i don't want to hear it and
that's a very
self-defeating mindset because it's like
if you don't know you have a problem you
can't fix it
right which is as we always say the
biggest problem a person can have so
the whole don't judge me thing no matter
what you're talking about is
i feel like it's always been a silly
concept
and shout out to evan murad the time
traveler for always going through these
videos
adding in these timestamps because bro
this brother's out here just going
through this like damn
is this going to be a clip for the
highlight for the to roast them is this
going to be a clip for the
timestamp like you got he's not just
watching it like y'all
he's out here like on cognition like
y'all but he's on metacognition
with the highlights he's on meta
metacognition with like okay could this
be a timestamp could this not
he's on something like damn should i
like look out for this [ __ ] or not so
he's doing the most man so shout out to
you have you ever seen the
the hangover no
you have you remember alan yeah when
they were going into the casino
and like he just had like all these
numbers like floating around in his head
that's how the there was his name eben
even imam yeah
[Music]
that's probably what he got going on is
that when he's watching that video i
mean
bro let's be honest now come on we don't
we won't know how he looks
that's true bro he's got the fact that
he's avatar
yeah bro he has uh here's the peter
griffin avatar
peter griffin got the uh
the nutsack chin the nut section yo
you should tell him you should tell him
to uh
update his dp and like make it to where
it's the uh
peter griffin with the beard yeah
because he already has the head on the
hat on yeah yeah yeah i've seen it i've
actually seen it so you should update
that
maybe halal
[Laughter]
inshallah all right gentlemen inshallah
allah listen
all right remember guys just a brief
recap get your fasts and
before ramadan during ramadan and after
ramadan may allah bless you all
with that being said thank you for
tuning in
in the first place to bring about the
change in this world
men were sent as prophets all prophets
were men
um it is in accountability as a
responsibility
the best example is the process so you
look at they look at
omar uthman all the sahaba khali one of
my favorite hamza you know one of my
favorite hamza was
he was a lion hunter for god's sake you
know what i mean he just smashes abu
jahl you know he's just i've done my
degree in biology and psychology
neuroscience and cognition okay and i've
done
research as i said in parkinson's so
i've looked at you know
human cognition behavior family
psychology early child psychology
then i've done education okay a degree
in education
and curriculum um then i've done a
bachelor's in islamic studies in sharia
then i've done
additional qualification in counseling
and existential counseling positive
islamic positive psychology counseling
finishing now a degree in positive
islamic psychology counseling here in
malaysia
doing a master's also in education from
university of malaya
inshallah hopefully finishing up this
year in uh islamic curriculum
and counseling in islamic schools
and now all of a sudden they took the
red pill and they wake up and it's a
reactionary movement so what they do is
they bump on they jump on the other side
and start pressing people they start
talking
smack and the things are not good they
start committing sins and they
because it's reactionary see for islam
masculinity is not a reactionary thing
so i had a i had a dream once
one night that i was yeah and i got
stabbed and i died you know and then i
think that's the one that really
it was so vivid and that's the one that
really uh
pushed me to say you know what god if
tomorrow i die am i really
you know i know what's right why am i
hesitating i really
this is our our dojo here
so you know enough space to spar and
everything it's like
it's quite big that we have four bags
and uh you know like our sparring stuff
here and whatnot yeah
that's what's up
[Music]
hmmm
[Music]